like you were at that remember the
unfound used to live in that apartment
building that's where you and I had an
amazing conversation I said I wouldn't
bring it up it was you know it was an
intimate conversation we had a
heart-to-heart that I don't know if
either one of us were expecting we
thought we were just gonna shoot the you
know having forget what I think it was
about some hands traffic yeah yeah yeah
it was it was just I think we were just
wasn't the thing that you about my
sexual things that I would do it wasn't
about sexual things or towards B that
sounded weird no this is what the
hugging and what I was known for I just
was like didn't like me for this was I
was known for like you like if I see a
guy yet it loved you I knew I would grab
onto them and squeeze their ass or I
would force very long more like a half
an hour for like maybe like a good
realistically like 40 seconds that's a
long time for somebody to embrace you
and go hi you on the back he's the only
one until only one in in life right that
I've ever done that's this too that
figured out the antidote yes right I saw
it coming
I remember where we were I heard excess
[ __ ] show yeah and then um you tell him
what happened and so I see I see Billy
come in and I'm like he's gonna he's
gonna he's gonna be lying right over to
me and so I prepared myself and when he
got right up to me I turned I bear hug
you and I fell on the floor on top of
you yeah and I took that 40 seconds and
parlayed it into about I didn't let you
go for at least two and a half minutes
he did this
what you do [ __ ] move it was so
intruder
after that I stood up and I go oh I
can't do that - amazing you literally
retired her right there I did I won't do
that to you again
I never did that again and you know who
heard about that and did it was rent as
Izzy Steve Rannazzisi heard that you did
that and he did it to me too and I never
did it to him again that was literally
the antidote right but you guys in this
room are employees and I'm gonna say
this right now right there is no
antidote
there is no pathway out mm-hmm you take
it that's not sure because I remember
when George went to the mountains and he
sent you a dick pic and it made you feel
very very confident I know can I say
this though what we were talking about
earlier right is still brochette right
it's like yeah you know hazing it's like
you know we're college kids you know
having fun
what he did was homosexual that right
yeah when you sent a dick to somebody a
dude another dude that's tasteful was it
flaccid or or was it like it was half
that was it a katana the tip of Florida
it was you know and you know that it
could have been either full at one point
or it's getting full but it wasn't
flossing
[Music]